one thing women can do that men can't do  is to weaponize their tears do you know  what I mean if a guy cries his tears  aren't weapons but if a woman cries she  knows her tears of weapons she can have  people believe her if she cries guys  don't get afforded that same thing are  you sure about that yes yes so when a  guy cries you know he gets made into a  meme where Michael Jordan cries was made  into a meme when Will Smith was crying  he was made into a meme when all of  these guys are crying they get made into  memes that mean to means it's not the  women making but not even that I'll just  see you but why are you why are you  offering an excuse  how is that because how do you even know  that how do you know who's making the  memes because mean culture typically is  pushed by men I was speculating but okay  we don't have to pick women women women  are the majority on social media